okay shall we we rolling camera no
here's johnny
[Music]
hello my name is george moats my job is
to preserve
hamburger history and give it to you how
about this one the cuban
fritta invented in cuba obviously many
many years ago and to me one of the
greatest cuban-american
gastronomic expressions but
unfortunately the cuba the cuba
sorry the cuban fritos alive and well in
miami and that's important because
you actually can't really find a good
fritta in cuba anymore
that's because thanks to many decades of
communist rule
all those ingredients are not available
anymore in 1959 cubans began to flee
their country following the cuban
revolution
and many settled in miami only about 200
miles away
the frida was one of the culinary
survivors of the exodus
sharing the same dna as the american
hamburger the frida was served from
street carts in havana before fidel
castro seized control of the country
i don't see the talia oh it is okay
you're rolling ruby okay
marker people who know me know me as a
purist and i
wouldn't normally consider a hamburger
or something with with stuff
in the meat this is the one exception i
do make basically it's an american
hamburger with a lot of spices
inside the meat but honestly really get
a good one you have to go to el mago you
have to go to el rey de las fritas
all these great places that are in
little havana in miami that's where
you're going to find a great
great cuban free town the beef is very
important
in my recipe to two pounds of ground
beef i've added grated onion
two garlic cloves two tablespoons of
paprika
some cumin pretty much the spices you'd
find in chorizo
we got a flat top and a hot flat top now
all the fritta emporiums of
little havana use a flat top also the
only way to make it you'll see why
i also have a special red sauce
this sauce is very important this sauce
actually lubricates the burger when it's
on the flat top
it's basically water apple cider vinegar
hot sauce
sugar tomato paste garlic okay
i'm gonna make a patty right just like
in little havana they smash it thin
they also add some onion right now but
once they smash it thin
they use this red sauce on it check this
out
that bubbles up all around it
[Music]
okay flip you can see that the look at
that
it's almost like it's actually burned
but it's because of all those spices and
things in the burger it browns very
quickly
let that cook down now what i have over
here is a classic cuban
roll it's the cuban hamburger roll this
is actually from miami
we had this sent up to us this is an
authentic
cuban roll you can use any kind of hard
roll they would normally toast it
heat it up a little bit of heat
was that water water
so now we're done that's it the patty's
done patty comes off
onto the cuban roll follow me here ready
for this one
on top of that goes more onion these are
deep-fried julienned potatoes potato
sticks basically look at that
and to that we actually also add i
wouldn't normally ever do this
ever
no no no i'm trying to get in my head
here okay
ketchup is too sweet to put on a burger
people to be totally honest the real
reason i don't put ketchup on a burger
and you shouldn't either
is because it's a very overwhelming
flavor ketchup is very sweet
it takes away from all that beefy
greatness going on there
it's very sweet will i unfollow someone
on instagram if i see them using ketchup
now
i will i disrespect them oh definitely
it's too sweet
my kids don't put ketchup on my burger
that's
crazy what kind of a dab would i be if
my children were putting ketchup on a
burger i think we had ketchup in this
house
we have ketchup in this house it was
hidden in the back i appreciate this
burger so much
it is the one burger one of the very few
burgers i'll actually
have put ketchup on it's part of the
experience
and it actually does work really well
with this and there it is that's the
cuban frittata
that's my version of the cuban frites at
least i know everybody in miami miami's
laughing but
hey you know what i think i did a pretty
good job
oh that's good
actually really good
so yeah
here's the thing it's good
oh whoa
oh good if you go to florida
and you go down to south beach you owe
it to yourself
to get your ass off the beach cross 95
and go over little nevada and try to
find a cuban free town
seriously you're not really in miami if
you're not eating like this
sorry
[Music]
god camera